can you hear me welcome to the meeting
this evening this morning
um you're all very welcome i will ask
uh the government's officer please to
read the
order of proceedings from all the
proceedings of the day and
the firing and domestic instructions
thank you thank you chair please ensure
that you
maintain social distance from all other
persons in the chamber
and in all the social areas please
ensure that you wear a mask unless you
are speaking
or if there are a few are unable to do
so and that
you use hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting
and during any breaks please ensure that
microphones are muted when you are not
speaking
and that you do not interrupt the other
speaker members are reminded that they
should
not have alternative communication lines
open i.e
other teams chats and that if you are
contacted by a third party during an
application
you should bring this to the legal
advisor's attention which is mr duprey
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair of the
meeting and will be using the e-voting
for this meeting
on modern.gov the firearm fire safety
arrangements are as follows if you hear
the alarm please leave the building
immediately via the fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point on
ipswich town
football ground training pitch follow
the signs directing you to the fire
exits at each door
at the end of the floor and do not enter
the atrium the ground floor areas and
the walkways
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts and do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it's safe to do so
allow like to remind members everyone
present that the meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will have been deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and for the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public
and the press may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting
when they are the public and the press
are not lawfully excluded
make a chair thank you robert may i make
introductions
in to pray legal advisor stephen stroud
the strategic projects and delivery
manager planning
and robert carmichael our covenant
officer you've met
and the case off at samantha summits
can i move to the agenda please yes fine
do we have any apologies for absence
thank you chair we have apologies of
absence this morning from councillor
adrian osborne and councillor peter beer
and i believe councillor jan osborne is
subbing for councillor adrian osborne
this morning
thank you to receive declarations
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members
are there any to declare
thank you we move to
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 19th of may
have you are there any points of
accuracy regarding
the minutes
no thank you um could i have a proposal
thank you councillors a secondary please
counselor mclaren thank you
you now conduct an electronic vote
please thank you chair
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov app and go to today's agenda
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner if members could please go
on the subsection on voting slash
attendance
and then click the click on the light
blue colored vote that is currently in
progress
so
thank you chair all votes have now been
received so that is nine votes for
with one abstention so that is carried
thank you to receive notifications
petitions in concordance for the
council's petition scheme
over to you rob none received chair
thank you site inspections before we
begin
the discussion on site inventing site
visits i would like to make an
announcement from the chair
as regards them i have seen
a number of emails suggesting we carry
out site visit on this
particular planning application i've
also seen the advice from the chief
planning officer this doesn't mean we
should look to go on a committee site
visit
but we should be very careful to ensure
if we do
it's covered secure
i therefore would like to suggest from
the chair that we hear the officer's
presentations
and the public speakers and we will
then be able to make sense of the issues
and possibly
consider a site visit or whether with
enough information by then
i would like to make a proposal to do
that
we'll have a secondary thank you council
busby
that was easier than i thought
okay moving on scheduler planning
applications
before we move into 6a dc
2003 247 i would just like to confirm
that
council mccarran is staying on the
committee
as well as being a ward member for one
of the parishes present
uh chair i'm staying on the committee
thank you thank you
i will now invite the case officer
samantha summers to introduce the
application
to the committee
thank you chair um before we start i'd
just like to draw your attention to the
table of papers
there were two table papers for this
application
one was a representation from uh
wolverson parish council
and the second is a change to the
recommendation
can i just check that all members have
had the opportunity to have a look
through
the table of papers before we start the
meeting please
yeah okay so um good morning everyone
this application comes to committee
because it is a major development
the application seeks full planning
permission for the erection of 22
dwellings two of which are affordable
dwellings
an extension to the village hall car
park a public open space
landscape enhancements
and cycleway links to
the nearby villages of holbrook and
chelma distance
i have got quite a long presentation for
you today there's about 45
slides so if something does
if you have any questions about a
particular slide
if you wouldn't mind just making a note
of the number so that we can
click backwards and forwards quite
quickly to answer any questions that you
have please
the application site extends over four
different parishes
and covers a large area there are five
separate
small sites for housing these are
located
on a main road the first site is here
the second site is just here and the
third site is here
and there are further two sites on
harksteed lane
uh which are down here
but um all all of the housing um
is within wolverson parish apart from
site one which is in
actually technically within preston but
sits right on the boundary
with uh wolveston and preston
uh the cycleways cover uh all four
parishes of preston
wolveston chalmerston and holbrook
and they are these pink lines here that
go down
to uh holbrook here and a further one
across here that extends to chalmer
distant
pristine village is actually up here
so site number one is actually quite
detached from preston and it reads
better with wolverstone village
which is just here we have
uh holbrook down here
and chalmer distant over here in the
east
this slide shows the proposal in context
to the existing development of auburn
so you can see the housing that is
existing along here
and we have site 1 just up here site 2
site 3 site 4
and site 5.
uh the green dotted line uh which you
may faintly be able to see just here
um is the parish boundary between
preston and um walvistan
uh the blue dotted line shows the post
cycleways
which again are here and then down here
to charmedista
the links to the village of holbrook and
also
links to uh sites four and five
they propose uh cycleways as well um
which are just here and up here
this slide shows the built-up area
boundary of wolverstone uh which you can
see
is in several different parts actually
there's uh
one section here there's this section
uh north of main road but there's also
some just to the south of the main road
just here as well
the red stars show the sites proposed
for the housing
all of the sites are outside of the
built-up area boundary
wolverstone is classed as a hinterland
village in policy cs2
of the core strategy and therefore cs11
has been used to assess each site
it is important to remember that
although each site has been assessed
separately this application is for the
whole proposal
and therefore a split decision cannot be
made on the application
as you can see from this plan sites one
four and five one
four and five um do not join
the built-up area boundary of walvistan
um
site two sits opposite and site
uh three actually sits between
two built-up area boundaries and also
opposite it
other than the built-up area boundary
there are several other constraints to
the development
the suffolk coast and heath's area of
outstanding natural beauty
lies to north of main road which is
shown in green
sites two and three are within the
wolverston conservation area
and that is shown by the purple line
that extends into the area of
outstanding natural beauty but also
to the housing development on the
southern side of main road
both the am aonb team and the heritage
team have raised no objection
to the scheme there are listed buildings
along main road home farm
sits on the opposite side of the road
from sites one and two
and shown with the blue star
there are also two listed buildings
either side of
site three we have burners hall which is
actually the village hall
and also the widows houses just here
all of those listed buildings are grade
two listed
looking at each site in turn this is
site
one the site is in the parish of preston
which is actually classed as countryside
in policy cs2
so they would need exceptional
circumstances
to actually allow housing in that area
although it is in the parish of preston
it does relate better
to wolverston and
that is because the housing of austin
finishes just here
there is a footpath along the main road
that starts at
these dwellings that neighbour that
property so the footpath starts here and
runs all the way through the village of
orbiston
sometimes it crosses over the road but
then it crosses back again
uh the proposal for the site is for
three pairs of semi-detached dwellings
with garages parking and gardens
the boundary of the rear gardens would
be in line with the existing dwellings
and a landscaping belt is proposed
between an existing farm track and the
development
this is the house design for site number
one they're three bedroomed houses
and have a very traditional style to the
front and it's a little bit more
contemporary to the rear of the
buildings
um i have used google images for all of
the site
photographs it's the easiest way to
explain
the sites one because uh you can see in
context with
uh the built-up area boundaries and the
development that's around
uh wolverstone but also um there's quite
high hedges in front of most of the
sites
um so actually getting anything that
is relatable for you to understand the
sides was quite difficult
and actually using google street view
because the camera is mounted on top of
a car you can see over the hedges in
most cases
so hopefully you'll find that quite
useful
this slide shows the site which is
this area just here between the farm
track and the existing houses
so the boundary would run along here
um it is on the edge of the development
along
main road there is currently a hedgerow
in front of the road
that is to be retained clearly any
hedging that is
in visibility space for all of the sites
will be
moved back so it will be taken out but
replanted
um the grade two uh listed dwelling of
home farm
is over the opposite side just here
so this is the uh last property
actually in main road in wolveston
and this is the site just along here
as you can see this is where the
footpath into the village actually
starts
this is looking back towards wolverson
village with that first dwelling
just here and this was the garaging that
you could see with the footpath in front
of it
moving on to site two this would
comprise
of two pairs of semi-detached dwellings
a landscaping buffer is also proposed
along the boundaries
um this is the house type very similar
in design
uh to the previous um uh dwellings
from site one uh they are um smaller
dwellings
um which have two bedrooms
um and uh they have a slightly smaller
uh um sorry
slightly smaller ground floor area
oh yeah sorry so uh there's actually two
different house types
on site too they're both two bedrooms
one has
this is the larger uh floor area that
you can see
just here and then the other pair
is the same design house but with this
area missing so it's a slightly smaller
house
um
the uh larger houses do have garaging
the smaller houses have
um just open parking bays to the rear
site 2 would be located just here in
front of these reservoirs
extensive landscaping has already taken
place
around the reservoir area which you can
see in this area here
further landscaping is proposed between
the farm track and the site
the built up area boundary is on the
opposite side
of the road just here
it contains those uh dwellings along the
road
the listed home farm
is just here
this is the application site um in front
of the banking
for the reservoirs so the houses would
sit in front of this area here
existing hedges to be retained again
with
um replanting of any hedgerow that's
removed
to make way for the visibility space the
footpath into the village is on the
opposite side of the road in this part
of the village
and this is looking in the other
direction so the site is here
with the footpath running into the
village along this opposite side of the
road
this is site three this is the site is
the most central
in terms of location within the village
the site sits between
two grade listed two grade two listed
buildings berners hall
to the west and the widow's houses
to the east of the site so village hall
here
and the widow's house is here the site
includes an extension
to the car park of berners hall which is
the village hall
and that is proposed just here
and a public open space is also
provided just here
two pairs of semi-detached bungalows
are proposed in this location here
uh 20 formal parking spaces are proposed
with parking for the overflow car park
and also further parking would be
available in the grassed area
just here if necessary four formal
parking spaces are provided
actually in the existing car parking
area
with a disabled space also the existing
access would be used
for all of the parking on this site
looking at a bit more detail of the
actual dwellings that are proposed
you can see them just here they have a
link through
through the open space to the village
hall
and this is the widow's houses that are
grade two listed
just here there are no garages proposed
for these dwellings but there are
parking spaces available
in this area and there's also some
outdoor buildings
sheds if you like provided for secure
bicycle storage
each pair of the semis comprise a small
one-bedroom unit
and a two-bedroom unit they are
traditional in style as well
now subservient to the widow's houses
adjacent to the site and design
and scale heritage had raised no
objection
to the scheme
this is site three in this area here
the car park extension would be just
here
open space here and the proposed
dwellings in this area
the site sits between two built up area
boundaries
that finish at burners hall and widow's
houses
and extend along there and along here
this is berners hall with the existing
access to the car
car park just here the footpath
through the village uh runs along the
front of the site
here
this is just moving down the site a bit
so this is the access to burner's hall
with the application site in this part
of the field here
so this would be the area for car
parking open space and then further up
towards widow's houses would be the
housing development
so this is where the bungalows are
proposed and you can just see the
outline of
widow's houses just here
these are the grade two listed widows
houses adjacent
site number three
moving on to sites four and five in
harvstad lane
these two sites are not considered to be
well located
to access facilities in wolverston
hargsted lane is a single track road uh
with
informal passing places there is no safe
haven for pedestrians because
of hedgerows and also there is banking
along the road these two sides are
considered to be
contrary to the development plan
this is sightful it proposes two pairs
of semi-detached dwellings
all with garaging a landscape buffer
is to be provided to the north of the
site just here
this is a bit confusing because it's
orientated slightly differently so uh
north is up here
in this direction
again very traditional looking houses
the dwellings would have three bedrooms
it should be noted that wolverstone is
quite a rare example
of an estate village which is associated
with wolveston hall
so this is why all of the dwellings that
have come forward have been
proposed in a nice red brick and quality
materials
but also have that very traditional
styling so they would fit in
with the street scene
so uh this slightly different colored
green here
is the application site for site four
the site is just north
of a small cluster of dwellings that you
can just see here
and there is a public footpath that
exists
along this field up into wolvestone
itself
this is one of the locations for one of
the cycleways
which would run along the rear of these
buildings here pop out at the bottom of
the road here
cross over into the applicant's field
run along here
south to site number five linking all of
the sites together
uh this is hangston lane and the site is
just on the left hand side here
again you can see that it's a slightly
uh different color
because it's not actually farmed
currently it's quite an awkward shape to
get the machinery into i suspect
the proposed dwellings would sit forward
of these overhead cables that you can
see
just here
there is an area of landscaping proposed
in this area with the houses tucked
behind
adjacent to the existing dwellings in
harvested lane
this is looking back towards the village
and the application site is on the right
hand side here
behind this hedgerow
these are some of the dwellings in the
small cluster to the south of the site
there is wide spacing between these
dwellings
the photographs are taken from the same
spot one looking
towards the village north and the other
one
looking south
this is site five and this is the one
that is at the southern end of parkside
lane
again it's proposing to have two pairs
of semi-detached properties
with garaging for each dwelling
this is the same house type as for
site number four which ties the two
sides together
and again they're three bedroom
dwellings
this is site number five in this area
here and sits between two clusters
of existing development this one here
and then this one on the corner of parks
did lane just here
uh again you can see the narrowness of
the harvested lane
and the application site is on the left
hand side here
this is just a photograph of the cluster
at the southern end of site number five
on the corner of the road
this is uh some plans of the proposed
garaging
for the dwellings
and this is the proposed garden stores
for plot number three
um as you can see both the garaging and
uh the garden sheds
they are all quite traditional in their
styling and materials that are used
this slide shows the street scenes
the top three slides are of site three
which
sits between the widows houses and
burners hall and it just
shows the scale of the houses
in context with widows houses
then we move on to site number one
which is the one that is technically in
preston
um that is the last house in the village
and then the houses would expense extend
out towards preston
and then this site down here is the one
that sits in front of the reservoirs
so site number two so you can see that
the houses are all well spaced
uh which is a feature of uh the houses
actually in the village um the estate
houses they're associated with
wolverstone hall
this plan shows the landscaping and the
biodiversity
enhancement that are also included in
within the scheme the green blotches are
the new landscaping
areas around the sites
that you can see here
two cgi's have been provided just to
give you um
an idea of how the science might look if
they were developed
this one is site number one which is the
one in preston
so these are the proposed houses just
here with the existing development along
here
and then this second one is a site two
which sits in front of the reservoirs
um there have been no objections
from consultees apart from some concerns
about the public rights of way
the concerns relate to the cycleways
which
in some cases actually run alongside
some public footpaths
the blue arrows show the public
footpaths on here so
the cycle link between wolverstone and
charmer distant
there is a public right of way that runs
along the field edge
there's this one that links site 4
to 2 wolveston center
that is a public right-of-way there is
also one
along here which is on the cycle way
proposed
to holbrook and another section along
here
the applicant has confirmed that the
cycleways will form a separate route
alongside the footpaths rather than
sharing a surface
with the public right-of-way uh details
of the cycleways
including their routes and surfaces will
be required by condition
should members be minded to approve the
scheme
cycleways would be subject to a section
106 agreement to ensure that they are
available
at all times for everyone
the affordable dwellings have been
offered by the scheme
this is clearly not 35 of the 22
dwellings
as required by policy however a
viability assessment was carried out
by the applicant this has been
to the district value valuer of the
consultation
who concluded that the scheme was only
just viable
with no affordable housing therefore the
offer of two
affordable units was generous in his
opinion
a full local needs assessment
did not accompany the application but
details of the parish survey from 2016
was used to inform the type of dwellings
for this scheme
members should be minded that this is
only
well it's quite old information now but
also
it's what people wanted or may want
not actually a proper needs assessment
the mix of dwellings on offer are one
two and three bedroom dwellings um
and four of those are bungalows these
are the type of dwellings
um that were shown up as being
something the villagers may want in the
future for the village
it's also the type of housing that baba
does have any district-wide need for
particularly the single story dwellings
where
people would be able to downsize but
remain in the village
i think um
it's particularly important to remember
that small villages
don't often have the opportunity to have
smaller
single story dwellings um it enables
people to downsize that already live in
the village and
may have either family or friend
connections
that enhance their life
villages often have very limited housing
stock
that don't include this type of housing
okay that was the last slide the
scheme is not policy compliant however
the public benefits on offer
are considered to make a strong case for
the proposal
wolverson has very little in the way of
facilities and amenities
there is the village hall the church
york club
and private school day-to-day amenities
can be found in the nearby villages of
chalmer distant and holbrook
chelmadistan is also classed as a
hinterland village
whereas holbrook is actually a core
village so has more facilities on offer
for people both of these villages have
shops schools public houses clubs
and holbrook also has a doctor's surgery
linking wolverstone by cycleways to
these two village
two villages is a benefit to existing
residents as well as to any future
residents
two affordable units are proposed
additional car parking for the village
hall
where parking can be quite difficult
along main road it's quite a busy
route some public open space is provided
in the centre of the village which is
linked with the village hall
and could be utilized for village
functions
enhanced landscaping and diverse
biodiversity enhancements are also
included in this application it is for
members to decide whether these public
benefits outweigh the harm
created by the two 222 dwellings in the
countryside the application is
recommended for
approval as set out in your agenda thank
you
thank you samantha are there any
questions for the officer
lee please counselor
thank you chair uh thanks sam it was a
great presentation
just a couple of points um firstly i'm
assuming the footpath
is not going to be extended towards site
one
and the other thing the parking
condition does that include the
electrical charging points and the
secure cycle sheds that i think highways
wanted to be put in
uh yes yeah there is secure
uh cycle storage for the dwellings
either in the sheds
or um in the garaging um
so that has already been addressed
electric
car charging points that may be
something that the
um agent would be able to clarify for
you what type of
[Music]
type of charging points they would be
etc
and the footpath is not being extended
uh
i don't think the path is to be extended
for site one no
thank you council johnson councillor lee
parker
thank you chad um sam i wonder if you
could just clarify for me
um woolston is currently designated as a
hinterland village
um but in the table papers the parish
council
contend that they shouldn't be
uh interland village and that in fact in
the forthcoming joint local plan
uh the designation is changed uh to
hamlet i haven't actually checked that
myself on taking that at
face value but assuming that that is the
case um
to what extent is the forthcoming jlp
material
and if it were the case would that have
any influence
on the on the recommendation now
thank you um yes so at the moment it is
classed as hinterland village
um you are correct because of the lack
of facilities
it will be downgraded to a hamlet um in
the forthcoming joint local plan
however we're still at early stages with
that at the moment so
we're giving that document limited
weight
our decision today is based on our
current policies
cancer jane osborne thank you mr
chairman yeah thank you sam
um i have several questions but they'll
only be relevant in the event that we
um proceed with making a decision today
rather than going for a site visit
however could you go back to slide 30
please
yeah there were several actually that um
that one is that the only access road
and
is it one-way traffic down there it
looks very narrow to me
so is that the only access road in and
out of that particular
site which i think was going to be site
four and possibly site five
uh yeah so uh sites four and five will
be
accessed from hargstead lane that is the
only access point
it is a single track lane
thank you
thank you chad thank you sam for that
presentation
um could you give me the distances
of the footpaths so the distance from
augustine to holbrook
do we know so not the foot past the
cycle path sorry
the distances between the two and the
distance between
wolverstone and chelma distant on that
cycle path
do we have that or am i asking something
sorry
yeah we do we do have that information
it will take me a few minutes just
because there's so many plans um unless
of course
this can wait for the agent who will
probably have that information
to hand yeah that's probably the easiest
way to do it okay thank
can you council mclaren any more
questions
councillor barrett thank you
sam thank you um can you uh say how may
and what the capacity of the car park is
currently
uh yes at the moment uh for the village
hall yes
uh yeah it's very informal so it's quite
a small space actually
the proposed plan is showing that
there's poor and a
disabled space that's probably quite
realistic i would assume
in order to get turning heads to get in
and out of there because it's quite
narrow access
so not many is the answer
cancer advisory yeah
it is very small because i tried to turn
my car around in it yesterday it wasn't
easy
um on the same point i think it's slide
17. i think you mentioned that the whole
entrance was remaining
i could have sworn i read somewhere that
it was going to be doubled in size
to a nate to allow cars to come into the
hall
rather than have to queue on the road
was i dreaming or was it
i'm not too sure on that point but again
the agent can probably clarify that
point for you
just follow up a little bit more on on
the um public space
than sam do you know if that is that
just going to be left as green
space or is it a sports field or
anything more
concrete i think at this stage is just
going to be
a green space with some landscaping
along the rear boundary i think probably
it will be up to the parish if they
decide that they want any play equipment
or anything like that on there that they
would be able to
use sill payments in order to pay for
for any of those facilities
any more questions for the officer no
thank you very much sam
for comprehensive report we're now
moving on
to public speakers as the application
crosses four parish boundaries
all four of the parishioners have been
invited to speak at this meeting
i will now ask representative for
wolverston parish council
to address us you have three minutes
good morning this application seeks to
find a way around planning restrictions
for building in the countryside
in our view it is a conjuring trick with
the psychopaths acting
as the glamorous assistant to take your
eyes off what is really happening here
that is building 22 houses in open
countryside in a protected landscape
and impacting on our heritage assets in
pre-application the developer was
advised they would have to demonstrate
exceptional circumstances and a proven
justifiable need
neither has been provided throughout
wolverson has been incorrectly
identified as a hinterland village
by policy cs2 a clerical error
identified it as such and has been
rectified in the emerging ejlp
to continue designating as such would be
irrational
wolverson is a hamlet and appropriate
policies should apply
a 21 growth is not appropriate for the
size
or character of our village the listed
buildings act states there should be
special regard to the desirability of
preserving the building
or its setting the heritage department
provided no analysis
or assessment of impact listed buildings
are not even mentioned by name
and dismissed in a single sentence
building between the widows homes and
burners hall
will harm its setting its connection
with the estate
and the experience of our rural past
will be irretrievably spoiled
the recommendation for approval is based
on public benefits outweighing the less
than substantial harm of this
development
there is no evidence of clear analysis
of this balance
who exactly are the beneficiaries the
car park
no evidence is offered to show a need
for a bigger car park
it is just planted there the burners
hall management committee will not ask
for a formal position
the open space residents don't want it
they're surrounded with quality open
space
cycle paths shortly peninsular cycling
campaign
object to the proposal because the cycle
paths are disconnected
the idea that there will be a modal
shift
is simply smoke and mirrors the garage
car park spaces shows the reality
another 44 cars
on the village rose the finnish survey
is five years old since then
15 houses have already been built in
walvistan
this is cherry picking to suit the
developers purpose
to talk about the size of properties
rather than the number
which is very clearly between five and
ten
this application is beguiling i urge you
to see it
for what it is an attempt to gain
planning permission where it wouldn't
normally be granted
this application runs contrary to both
weber's development plan
and the emerging jlp the planning
office's report
point 12.1 shared with the committee is
incorrect
matters raised by the wolveston parish
council have not been addressed
and i urge you to reject this
application
thank you thank you sir are you prepared
to say questions
yes yeah any questions for wolverson
parish council
no then i thank you sir moving on
there is no representatives from
charlemagne and there are no
representatives from preston they've
declined to attend today
i would now ask the objector stevie kent
to speak you have three minutes to
address the committee
we have a growing problem with the
volume of traffic through wolveston
noise speeding pollution and severance
are increasingly issues for residents
the transport assessment does not
include the cumulative impact of other
planning commitments in the area
eg additional flow of over a thousand
vehicles a day from the development of
hms ganges
the transport assessment does not
reflect the true figures for vehicle
flow
on the b1456 as it was carried out
during the school holiday
scc does not consider the site
sustainable
from a transport policy perspective
much is made of the cycle paths these
are not joined up
leaving the dangerous narrow stretch
through the centre of the village
being permissive they do not address the
long-term designation
no evidence has been put forward to show
a need for them no survey
no assessment shortly peninsula cycling
campaign
group have objected to the proposals
site by site
site one the historic entrance to the
village and marks the start of the
conservation area
entering from ipswich the agent's house
is on the left
and number one is on the right with the
beautiful gable end with decorative
barge boards
the historic presence and context will
be lost
site three the space between the widow's
homes and burners hall has existed for
130 years
it is at the heart of the open spaces
that are the essence of the village of
wolverstone
and will be altered considerably and the
significance of the widow's homes
diminished site 4 the heritage report
noticed buildings were
rather large we say two-story houses
built in
isolated flat open countryside
with no woodland soften impact will harm
the views across our
unique ancient estate landscape of
fields and woods towards holbrook
site five this wooded paddock in the
open countryside is haven for deer
moving from one wood to another bats
owls
woodpecker and even nightingales
this pepper pot approach to development
is a danger to the open countryside
and will lead to more building on
greenfield sites in rural areas
and the destruction of their rural
nature weber policies are designed to
protect these areas
and should not be circumvented there are
no
exceptional circumstances for building
here there is no
proven justified local need as the
council has 35
more properties approved than is
required
there's no pressure to approve an
application that does not comply with a
development plan
or bdc policies this application
should be rejected
thank you be prepared to answer
questions if there are any
yes any questions for the speaker
yes counselor thanks
how many times did the buses run through
the villages
um we used them yesterday four i believe
[Music]
and have you had much communication with
the agent
we had communication with the agent at
the very beginning of the process
he came to talk to us about what was
happening we had a
village meeting so plans could be
presented but in fact only a map was
presented
which showed the possible sites it
wasn't until the application
went live in august that we actually saw
what was proposed
on the for the application there were a
couple of
communications in the meantime yeah
thank you
any more questions thanks right here
um a quick one concerning
oh sorry concerning health care as much
as anything else i presume that
the residents of existing residents of
wolveston use
holbrook or shot leak surgeries they're
linked but
yes people choose that we'll we're sort
of equidistant for both
so presumably access has to be my car
because there's no
convenient bus service and if you're
sick you're not going to get on your
bicycle
absolutely and if you're in you wouldn't
get in the back and as far as children's
education is concerned
um children have to go either by car
or school bus to where
some choose to go to german distant
primary some to holbrook
um there aren't school buses to chelmo
though are there
to the primary schools it's high school
i was thinking of sorry when i said
school bus okay
thank you council reyes
thank you chair um you said that the
survey of the traffic was during the
school holidays
how significant is the difference
because you do have a lot of cars going
to the high school
uh it's huge yes the um
ipswich high school has originally they
planned to bring a lot of children out
by coach but
many have opted to be transported
privately
it's also the number of developments
that have been in the meantime in
charming distant and shortly so we have
all that traffic passing through
taking children to school or
wherever they're going yes thank you
i mean it's a it's a real problem for
our elderly just across the road at the
moment
um we have very elderly neighbours on
both sides and they really struggle
we go with them to the library van one
of them to help her to cross the road
any more questions if not
we're going to have a look oh sorry
sorry this is actually probably to the
parish
club council i guess you both could
answer the
the hall what use is made of the hall
is it just local or other other people
hiring
it it's uh used very little um
i can't think of more than four or five
occasions in a year
when you'd be talking about needing to
use an overflow car park and
uh jeff mayhew very kindly lets us use
our his beat patch which is next door to
the village
um hall um if we need to do that but
you'll be talking about four or five
times a year
i think the actual capacity of the car
park is closer to
six or seven cars rather than than the
four referred to but
yeah normally it's more small clubs
small meetings
thank you any more questions
thank you thank you i believe we now
have to take a little break while we
swap the speakers around
please don't disappear
thank you we can resume again um we
don't have a supporter
so i will now ask the applicants to
speak we have roger barma
and alistair davison i believe and can i
ask you to stay afterwards
and answer the questions that you agreed
to answer for the council
thank you you have three minutes
good morning members
my name is roger obama and i head up a
small design team in east berghoft
our clients are third and fourth
generation farmers in wolverston who
live both in
and close to the village this project
has taken three years of consultation
and planning to eventually come before
you today
it is a truly unique and complex
proposal
in which we have sensitively woven a
definable layer
of development and landscaping into the
grain of this historic village
we've undertaken a detailed process to
ensure that the proposal is well
considered
and appropriate this has been a
design-led exercise
driven by a client's desire to create
the best realistic
fit for the village as a whole rather
than purely
a monetary return based upon a financial
matrix
this is far from that we consider that
our consultation with experts in their
field
has provided us with an excellent
platform from which to propose this mix
of housing
its location scale and the character of
the architecture
with the considered landscape and
biodiversity proposals and the many
sustainable qualities
together with the significant public
benefits that are integral to this
project we believe that this scheme
delivers a
wholesome and realistic proposal for
wolverstone
that will help thwart disparate
piecemeal development
within this high quality village for the
foreseeable future
we've been through a process of deep
scrutiny to address the many constraints
that come into play
including the effect on the conservation
area the adjacent list of buildings
and not least the ionb we've sought to
balance the impact of the development
with the unusual opportunity to offer
very tangible public benefits
the connectivity provided by the new
psychopath links to holbrook
and chelman distant is extraordinary
the much needed additional parking and
access improvements for the village hall
and the adjacent public open space are
positive benefits
the provision of affordable houses the
small
and small bungalows is very much meeting
a local need
the overall mix of bungalows cottages
and houses of one
two and three-bedroom semi-detached
units is a response to the sensitivity
of this project
i am pleased that this application comes
before you today with no
objection from the vast majority if not
all
of the professional consultees i am
fully aware of the significance
of this project and i'm proud of the
proposal which is before you
i cannot do the details of this
expansive process
and the resultant scheme true justice
within my lot of three minutes here
however i'd be really pleased to answer
any questions and to talk through
some of the more tricky issues with you
thank you for your time class mclaren do
you want to start with your question
that
the asian degree director thank you
chair
um good morning mr obama um
could you give me the distances the
question i
asked before could you give me the
distances of the footpath oh
sorry that i will say the foot past the
psychopaths between the
the holbrook and wolverstone and chalmer
distant and wolvester
um between uh wolveston hall
um where it starts to just short of
german distance is about
0.75 of a mile 1.22 kilometers
and from just adjacent to bernie's hall
through to the
um beginning of holbrook is 1.67 miles
or 2.6 kilometers okay
so can i then follow that up with
another question
when these cycle paths were envisaged
and planned
who or what part of the population did
you think
might use them
sorry certainly we would expect both
village villages at either end to use
the past to get to wolverstone
and to get from holbrook to german
distant
through wolverstone we can't connect the
entire much has been made in this
process of the lack of connectivity in
the center of the village we simply
can't do that
we can we can offer um the provision on
the land that we have available
and there is a short section of road
which needs to be used
at the moment all of the road needs to
be used
similarly for people to get to the core
village of
holbrook from charming distant or indeed
from wolverston to to to holbrook
um will be significantly improved i've
traveled the road for
15 years daily on school trips with the
children
i know the bends as you come around from
the water tower and they are a nightmare
and this takes out that that provides an
opportunity to get rid of that
real problem um which exists
and i see that as a really key part of
this
also tourism i think that the tourism in
the district is obviously increasing
and the fact that people will be able to
circumnavigate the peninsula
without using the roads has to be a good
thing um
i'm aware of other projects where the
cycle path
network is uh is currently being
considered
and this is possibly the start
of a really progressive um
change where the cycle the cycling
within the district has improved and i'm
aware of the constant your own
consultation
which is taking place at the moment with
regards to the use of net
of cycle paths and such
um just an observation if um
this business about people in wolverston
using
hallbrook safe for the surgery and
perhaps the corp in fact for those sort
of journeys
i doubt very much that the majority of
people would use a bicycle
they would use a car wouldn't they
be sure but children to the children to
the shops
families to the shops to the school
there are many services in holbrook
which would definitely
attract attention from the psychopath
and make it a very useful proposition
thank you thank you thank you there was
one other question that someone wanted
answered by the agent
council advised me quickly though yeah
it was the
question about the entrance to the hall
i i'm sure i read somewhere where it was
going to be
expanded so that you could have an
in-out was that
we we see that as a as a definite plus
to the scheme
at the moment perhaps part of the reason
why the hall isn't used as much as it
could be
is because it isn't very accessible and
that could be partly the car parking
uh and the provision for functions there
the actual access itself is due to be
doubled so that two cars can drive in
and out at the same time
at the moment it's single track it's a
nightmare you have to reverse back onto
the road
or back into the car car so yeah
another one as well again i can't
remember whether
there's trouble with reading the reports
and also looking up at all the documents
online you never know which way you've
got them
um
it is better isn't it sorry um again
look
i think this mentioned of passing bays
being put on to
hark's dead lane yes
you're correct the situation in pakistan
is that
for most of the distance it is currently
single track
and they're up there it is difficult to
pass
as part of our proposal the new
entrances
to the two sites on harksted lane are
extraordinarily wide in the true sense
of the word
um to what they actually need to be for
those sizes of developments
and that has been uh incorporated
specifically to enable people to pass
and use those entrances for passing
and then there is an additional passing
place as well
which is proposed so there will be three
passing places created as a direct
result of what we're doing
councilor parker would you like to put
your question
um thank you i mean to an extent um
council mclaren
covered it actually but i will i will
just challenge mr palmer if if i can
um i i noted that you made mention three
times in your presentation about public
benefit
um and yet wolverson claim that there is
none um
so aside from the cycle paths um
what is the uh the public benefit that
should persuade us to
uh to to go against a lot of what is in
our in our existing core
that's strategy good question so of
course there are there
there are other cycle paths um that
there are also
i'm just trying to think if there are
actually any changes to the footpaths
themselves
there are um yeah there's a there's a
section of footpath currently
opposite home farm on the maps that's
450 mil or so wide it's not really a
path
and as part of what we are proposing
that path gets widened to 1.2 meters to
allow um prams and such light to walk to
to get through the village along along
the actual footpath rather than needing
to
surround the verge or onto the road
yes that's that's opposite home farm i
should also just point out one thing
which didn't necessarily come across
quite clear
clear earlier the
site one is connected via a footpath
to the village it isn't a remote site
that we are able to connect onto the um
the existing footpath that you saw on
one of the early slides
so the other coming counselor coming
back to you to your question there
the other public benefits as i see them
and this is off the top of my head
there's clearly the car park we go from
four
five maybe six spaces um
to 20 plus another
a good ten and to bring the village hall
fully into use and fully
safe we
we widen the width of the entrance as
i've just explained to councillor busby
there is the public open space we have
discussed with the village um
whether they would like children's play
equipment incorporated as part of that
and that was something which was
um uh not seen as a as something which
would be attractive or
desirable um and and indeed with regards
to the the increasing of the size of the
car park
um comments were made that it would only
increase anti-social behavior
which
is difficult to sort of accept um there
are landscape benefits included within
the proposal
as well um quite significant
biodiversity and and many sustainable
issues
thank you thanks for osborne thank you
mr chairman good morning
um my first question has been answered
on the single track because i did have
concerns about that so
it's been referred to in on several
occasions by both the planning officer
and one of the objectives that
development would only be approved under
exceptional circumstances
yes i would find it very helpful if you
could explain to me why you feel
that there are exceptional circumstances
to these five sites
please that's fine i to me it's really
clear
the the the public benefits which we've
just discussed and this is a once in a
lifetime opportunity to provide a cycle
path
and the connectivity between the
villages which will not happen again
and given the mix of
of of housing which is proposed right on
the money
with what we are all looking to do in
providing the smaller units
there is a need for it there's no
question about that um
it's for you to decide whether
wolverstone is the right place for it
but it's you know the bungalows the
semi-detached the smaller units the
downsizing
to free up the larger units we'd have to
keep building the larger units
all of that carries i in my mind strong
muster
um and
the opportunity to to weave that in to a
scheme which
gets this significant benefit
and and i would say exceptional
circumstance of being able to
connect over nearly three miles
of the peninsula is
compelling
another question is um will you be
picking up any of the schemes that are
currently in place
for specifically on this on these
smaller homes
for key workers for first time buyer key
workers
no i i i can't say that is that is
something which is being considered no i
i can't sign his no
thank you yes councillor jameson
thanks yeah morning
on your design statement you um you say
you're incorporating a lot of
feature feature sustainable design
features
but looking at these a lot of them sound
aspirational rather than
um commit commitments like yours for
example you're saying you're considering
thermal bridging rather than eliminating
it
you're doing well proportioned double
glazed windows rather than high
performance
and you're considering embodied energy
rather than minimizing it
and i just wonder if these are
commitments or just
aspirations as i say and if also if
they're on every property
and also as i asked the officer
are you including electrical charging
points in the premises
so thank you
the electric charging points are
proposed for each
house um it is our intention
and the design of the units
have been conceived to incorporate all
of the benefits
which are indicated on the list in the
design statement
if the wording isn't quite correct it is
a commitment which i can make now
that we would definitely uh you know
this isn't
just speech it's thorough and proper
yeah thank you any more questions
sorry um i'm going to ask the same
question as ask parishes you've been
doing this
for three years how many times did you
meet with the parishes
in these three years
i would need to check my notes to given
to give a
absolutely factual answer um and i
believe the parish's response was
was accurate in in terms of uh their
written response in terms of
um the chronology of events um there was
an initial meeting
which set out the parameters of what we
were looking to achieve through the
scheme
um there was subsequently a public
meeting
from which there was a squat analysis
and uh
several well a good number of emails
which were exchanged and forwarded to me
simon was very cooperative with that
and the swot analysis was really key for
us
to make sure that we were hitting the
mark as much as we could
uh run parallel with the survey of 2016
with the offering that we were to put
forward and as many of those items which
came out of that have been incorporated
there was then a subsequent meeting with
the
uh certainly with the village hall
committee
thank you chad um good morning um
you've answered quite a few questions
about the
the design and the the sustainability i
just wondered
also on the heritage aspects of the the
appearance the exteriors
because this village is it's got quite a
unique identity really um and
um i believe that you know the
what's called for is very high standard
of
of appearance um to to conform with that
can you sort of describe a little bit
more
we've not been able to see from those
drawings they're not detailed enough for
us to appreciate
what might be uh included in your design
that's a great question thank you um
so the design and there's there's a huge
amount of thought which has gone into it
um and
conversations with the heritage officer
and design officer at um
at the council um to make sure that
we're all aligned in
in what we think is the right response
design response
um the use of red brick is synonymous
with wolverstone it's what's there
and similarly the the use of peg tiles
on the roofs we've sort to make sure
it's been really clear and we've been in
agreement from the onset
that it's very important that this is a
readable
layer of development not something which
is mishmash and ad hoc
to to just fit in with the next door
house we should see this as a definable
uh uh
yes liar is the word of of what happened
in between 2021 and 2025
um in exactly the same way as the phase
which the burners created 140 odd years
ago
is very very tangible within the
existing arrangement
we've sought to put um
a a a a a few elements of contemporary
architecture within
um that essential palette of the peg
tiles and the
uh and the brickwork and if you're able
to look at the drawings at some point
there is a detailed um elevation which
shows some clever brickwork
um the windows are slightly recessed the
windows are
powder coated aluminium the detailing on
the carrot the parapets down the side
and the chimneys themselves is all in
zinc
it's we haven't held back and we haven't
been asked to hold back
and it's important to say that with
there's 500 odd thousand pounds worth of
public benefits
plus the sale money which is
incorporated into this
and and when that is
uh aligned with the cost of
of the high quality architecture and the
landscaping which we're proposing
that is the reason why there are no more
affordable units than
what there are and sam made reference in
the earlier
presentation um uh to the fact that
the the uh tony williams is um response
to
our uh uh um
the viability assessment sorry thanks
for at my words right um
was that it was barely um viable
with no affordable units and we've taken
the view
that it's important and it is another
public you know it's another benefit
which comes out of this
and we've seen it as important to
incorporate some so we've put two in two
units the two units
on site two which don't have a garage
are proposed to be the affordable units
we were really concerned that we
wouldn't get any
providers to buy into just two isolated
units in the countryside that we've
spoken to hasto and they are
willing to take those on one as um
as a rentable property and the other as
a shared ownership
um could i ask those um
you said that some of the you hoped that
people would downsize to make the
larger houses more available in your
design
are they homes for life would because
if some of them who are downsizing maybe
elderly
you know how are the um what facilities
have you got
would any have a wet room or they've got
wide doorways in case they end up in a
wheelchair
sorry um although not specifically
complying with homes for life the one
and the two bedroom bungalows both
incorporate
you know their wet rooms on the ground
floor they have they have wider doorways
um uh and um you know i think i think
also the the um affordable homes has to
have quite specific requirements on on
spaces around
rooms and and turning circles and and
all various things so those
you know uh six units would all be
suitable for
for downsizers or or um less mobile
people yeah
counseling claim would you back up
yes joe can i just check with ian
when sam gave her presentation
um there was a you alluded to the
low level of affordable housing that was
within this application
is that all right for me to continue to
ask a question in that vein
of course thank you thank you thank you
um
when people apply for to develop
different areas there there is been
a rule that affordable housing anything
over a certain
number then affordable housing applies i
think it's over 10.
can you just explain to me why your
application is actually for 22 houses
it's coming as one application can you
explain to me
why there is only two houses that have
been
allocated for affordable housing when
actually
shockley peninsula actually needs
affordable housing
thank you
so that's a very good question again
the the cost
of this as a project to
i know it would be appropriate at some
point if i can to explain
why we're doing this what's the
rationale behind it what is it about
what's the driver
but um i personally can come on to that
uh
the the
cost of this as a project to deliver
the benefits and the high quality
architecture
to the level which we believe it needs
to be in the heritage and conservation
setting to get this really right and
appropriate
in in terms of the design but also the
package as a whole
so that we feel that it it
it hits a sensible balance
has led us to 22 units
and the two affordables it's it's the
it's the viability
assessment which has told us that at
22 units it's barely viable
with no affordable units incorporated
so to to to to to help
with the balancing and and and the
benefits
we've put two in because we feel it's
important as part of the package as a
whole
those two units come at a cost
of about 142 000 pounds
the cycle path is 235 000 pounds
the car park is about 39.5
thousand pounds excuse me i i don't
think we need it
this
any more questions for the agent
no then i thank you very much and i'll
ask you to
stand down and now i'm moving into
debate is that correct
thank you this is customary
if a ward member is here has not spoken
to the ward member
that your art are invited to open the
debate
you do not have to accept that
invitation by the way but
the invitation is there people to start
the debate
okay thank you yeah does anybody else
like start debate
close to the park
super job i'll kick off there um
gosh it i mean it really is a finely
balanced application
in my opinion um and i'll be i'll be
glad to
to hear the um considerations of of my
colleagues but
um i just sat and drew a thoroughly
informal pros and cons table um to sit
here
uh and as i was sitting here sort of
thing and um
i i've got some serious reservations i'd
have to say i'm a big fan of mr obama's
work ordinarily um
and i i don't think that this
application itself is objectionable it's
it's
quite an attractive scheme i think um
but there are some serious
considerations um in so far as
it is against policy in the whole or in
in the main so that's a serious
consideration for us to
because what's the point of having a
policy um if we don't adhere to it
um uh affordability is a major issue for
me
um chair as well um i i fully accept
what the applicant is saying but
nonetheless
there is an obligation to provide a
certain amount of affordability and
it is regretful that um that the
applicant feels that
this scheme would be unviable but that's
something that we're gonna have to take
into account isn't it i mean the rules
are the rules
there should be what nearly eight
affordable units there should be
nearly eight affordable units here no
needs assessment
um that's quite a serious consideration
um
part of it is out in the countryside so
could potentially be deemed as
um as being in an unsustainable location
um i'd quite like to flesh out a little
bit more if i could because sam i'm not
i'm not entirely sure that
you answered my question with regards to
the you know the hinterland village and
things i mean
i think my second question was maybe
it's a bit unfair but
the second part of my question was is if
if this weren't
a hinter or if if wolverstone sorry
because i know we're taking it
as whole but if wolveston weren't a
hinterland village
would that have a bearing upon the uh
upon the recommendation
um because i think this is what is
absolutely key
from from certainly from my point of
view is the fact that it
that that world is designated as the
interland village
um i i also have to consider what our
deliberations here would mean in the
event
of a potential appeal if members were
minded not to support this application
um and i just think that that would be
an extremely difficult
thing to uh to justify
if this committee were minded to uh to
not support the application
in an appeal um
is designated as a hinterland village
and that's that that's really all there
is to it i think
um so that that's that's all the
comments that i'll make at the moment
um chair thank you can i would you like
me to get the officers
to comment on those comments right
please do
stephen straub and then sam to follow it
by me
more than happy to um chair and yes
sorry i'll take this off while i'm
speaking
um if i could actually start councillor
parker just with the affordable housing
point just to just to make clear on that
there's no
there's no express conflict with that
particular policy in this instance
because the policy does envisage
that there will be there will be
circumstances where viability comes into
account and so long as that
that case is justified and in this case
we've we've made made use of the
district valuer
um then the policy is capable of being
complied with
in in the sense that there's a case been
made it's been accepted and quite simply
it's not
possible to secure the 35 percent that
we ordinarily would seek to
seek to achieve um on the broader points
um i think the bottom line is in in
policy terms within the context of the
development plan
this is a hinterland village it plays a
role within its functional cluster
and that's the purpose of the spatial
strategy that we've got notwithstanding
that
i fully appreciate and i think you know
there are valid points made earlier by
the parish council
that the emerging plan is taking a
different direction and of course it's
an entirely different
different strategy um that as a material
consideration as
a document and and as a process at the
moment the the emerging plan we would
afford limited weight to it
but that's not to say that the
importance of what's been put forward to
you
is is immaterial in the sense that
wolverstone has its own particular
issues from a sustainability perspective
and i think then this plays into the
the the challenge the real challenge
that you've got today members which is
that
in accordance with what the what the
officers have told you this is a scheme
which is contrary to the development
plan when viewed as a whole
and really what we're looking at here is
weighing up that particular harm and any
other harms which is quite important
obviously harm to the planned lead
system and we have an up-to-date plan
versus what are the appellate the
applicant is commending to you
are very very uh important and
particularly weighty benefits
whether you agree they are is is really
for your for your judgment whether
they're of dubious utility or they
actually are of real value that that's
for you to weigh up and weigh up against
that that harm and reach
your your conclusion
jan you dan osborne counselor please
thank you mr chairman
i actually concur with a lot of the
concerns that councillor parker has
raised
in particular the affordable housing
element for obvious reasons
and i just think i'm just concerned that
that will actually set a president for
other applications coming forward and
although i understand the financial
viability
i do feel that we need to stick to
policy in this particular case
i'd like to follow that up with a
question if i may i know we're in debate
but i do have a question
if the application is approved and
there's there's two there for affordable
housing
will they be will the allocation be
based on local connection
need only rather than babel wide
on the whole of gateway choice um
well we don't have the benefits of our
strategic housing team
here too sorry i'll just put them take
it off again i don't have the benefits
of strategic housing team here to answer
that particular question what they'd
want to secure but i can tell you that
in general terms
and what i would expect in this case is
that they would be for the district um
district needs um and as you're well
aware council hospital i mean the the
the council's position on affordable
housing as a district is
is um it is not excellent um
and therefore you know as a benefit
affordable housing is
you know is important whether it's two
units or the eight
and and just to get back to that policy
point this is in compliance with the
affordable housing policy because a
viability case has been made and
has been accepted um
councillor bathroom well you're kind of
keeping on with the affordable housing
thing of course if they
applied for five individual applications
there wouldn't be a requirement for any
affordable housing
and i think if we think about it
as on a site rather than
an application i think that probably
makes more sense i mean i'd
having driven down they around it
yesterday and down parker's plane
there's actually a conversion of white
house farm which is
seven four bedroom huge units
we're not going to get anything out of
that no affordable housing no
benefits whatever i don't think and
here we are i guess trying to provide or
try they're trying to provide some
houses which
could fit the needs
and we're getting some benefits as well
i mean normally when we do this
calculation and it is a tough
calculation
the benefit to weigh up the benefits
against the harm
the benefits normally only consist of
where you're getting some houses
well i think we're getting a lot more
than that in this instance
um i for one that that if i was
still capable of doing it the cycle path
from german distant to
holbrook i think it's probably going to
be one of the most pleasant cycle routes
that you could take it's a fantastic bit
of
countryside round there one
thing one criticism i may have is that
will the applicant maintain the
cycle paths and the footpaths do they do
the footpath as well
do they maintain the footpaths across
the land at the moment
only they they're in desperate need of
somebody to go around
and widen them there i think you might
get one person walking along them but
you
certainly wouldn't get a push chair or
um
uh you know mobility vehicle down there
or anything like that so
providing they can be maintained at a
better level than the footpath and i
think will be useful
addition
okay mclaren i just correct uh
councillor busby the footpath is not
it's not tell the distance to holbrook
that would be a very good footpath it's
wolverston to holbrook
so it's a bit shorter um i feel we're
getting a bit distracted
by the offer of and the development of
the cycle pass
for anybody that's familiar with the
chocolate peninsula in fact the serious
cyclists
would not consider entering the
peninsula and then turning right or
turning left depending which village
they were in
as they enter the chocolate peninsula
the serious cyclists have a proper route
around um shotlift and insula
and and all for enhancing
as a ward member i'm all for encouraging
and
enhancing the cycle routes but i think
in this application
the cycle paths are a destruction
thank you
um yeah as we stated i mean there's a
they don't actually fit with the
development plan and even if sites
one two three are close to the built-up
area boundary
i'm a bit concerned about sites four and
five i mean they're down hark's dead
lane so they're way out in the
countryside i believe
and also it's a single track lane which
is um
so it is a bit of a concern
thank you councillor hinton please
thank you mr chairman yes i agree with
councillor jameson there
i think one of the problems we've got
with this application today is that it's
a sort of take it or leave it
application we can't cherry pick around
the five
or six or seven different elements of it
we've either got to take the whole thing
together
as one or reject the whole thing as one
and i think that is the major problem
with it
the other thing is that it is contrary
to a lot of plan
a lot of our local pla existing local
plan and the proposed new
local plan and to the infrastructure
strategy
and to all sorts of other parts of our
policy and i can't
see where the benefits are
going to offset that looking at it as a
whole
i think we've got to say that it's
contrary to our plans
go away and think again even if you come
back with five
individual applications then at least we
can look at the merits
or or problems with each individual part
of the application
whereas at the moment we've got to take
the whole thing as one and
far too much of it it's completely
contrary to our planning
and if we if we if we approve it as it
stands at the moment
i'm afraid we might as well throw our
local plan and everything else in the
bin because
we're not going to be using it at all
thank you council hinton anyone else
any kind councillor baron thank you jack
um
we we've uh discussed housing needs
survey for wolverson
um some of these villages are actually
in preston is there a housing needs
survey
that preston have completed
uh yes so site one is in preston
um i'm not aware that the village has
actually uh
done any sort of surveying at all okay
thank you
um yes just
sharing my thoughts really it is it is a
difficult one
i mean the what we've seen looks very
acceptable the the design the layout the
spacing
the respect for the existing
uh houses and the
um i think sensitivity that's that's
shown it seems
seems to respect the village and the the
identity
um
it's rather it's rather a difficult one
for us um
as they normally are um
i i i do i do think you know the
benefits
not just the cycle routes but they do
seem to
provide quite a an attractive package um
the
the village hall um the benefits i mean
there is an undeniable benefit there um
and the the open space
but um it is it is a finely balanced one
i'm not
really sure about the the um the the um
complying with policy
thank you council barrett anyone else
like to join the debate
if not i need to have
a proposal and a second day
on what your decision is councillor
bozeman
well uh yeah just taking up the one
final point
uh
i'm not saying it's only wolvestone
parish council but it
apart from wolverson parish council most
other bodies can
consultees seem to be in favor of it or
don't object
to this and here's a recommendation from
our officer
that we accept it
i get on balance therefore
i'll be prepared to propose that we
accept the officer's recommendation
thank you council adversary do you have
a second day
thank you chair yes um i again looked at
it from both sides
and i think we should go um with the
officer's recommendation and i would
propose that
we sent our second accommodation your
second council votes with motion
all right we have a motion
unless there's any more comments we will
go to a vote
thank you robert thank you chair i've
just
updated the recommendation in
modern.gov and just to read as follows
so that all members are aware because of
the update from sam's
table papers so that it includes that so
it now reads the application dc2003247
be approved as detailed in the updated
officer recommendation
in the table papers is that correct sam
as well
just a double check yeah that's correct
and just to make it clear
the thing that has changed is on the
section 106
the cycle ways would be protected and
also the highways improvements included
on a section 106 legal agreement
are you happy for me to proceed
oh sorry
apologies it was just to clarify that
obviously bearing in mind
um some of the one of the questions that
we put to put to the agent
and the response um i don't know whether
in your deliberations
proposal and secondary that as you were
weighing up
the benefits as material considerations
here that you were you were weighing in
that commitment for these dwellings to
be of a particularly high
standard in efficiency and
sustainability terms and if that were
the case i think it would be prudent for
us to secure that by way of condition
yes i agree
sorry wanna turn my head away can't hear
me
um yes the proposer and secretary are
both willing to accept that
right so with that in mind share so i
will update to say
and with the additional um condition as
read out by
the um strategic planning and delivery
um
which is what mr stroud has just read
out if that's acceptable
thank you
quality foreign that we've heard are
wrapped up in your list of
conditions are they
um yes some of them are but if the
sustainability one
we could have that as a separate
condition added to
the decision notice if members vote to
approve the scheme
because obviously i think having seen
this is a full planning application
having seen the detailed design etc
and the fact that it does supposed to
marry in with wolverstone's
character we wouldn't want
any opportunity for that to be moved
away from
no that's absolutely right and i know
that the agent is very keen
that the houses are built as he has
designed them
so um you know he takes quite quite a
lot of pride in
what he designs so yes we do have
detailed drawings
um and i believe
just double check yep so
for example samples of brickwork
external materials rainwater goods
details of windows and doors eaves and
verges
the heritage officer has actually
required that condition
to agree those details is actually
included and that
is in the recommendation
thank you thank you do i take it now
that you're not going to change your
proposal
and your second has not changed anything
therefore can i now go and ask the
governance officer to begin the vote
thank you chair so that's now updated
with um the additional condition as read
out by the strategic projects and
delivery manager
so i'll now open the vote chair if
members could please go to the
modern.gov app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner of today's agenda
go to the subsection on attendance
voting
from there you will see in progress
the vote in a light blue color it's
right at the bottom so you may need to
scroll
down
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and the outcome of the vote
is seven votes four and three against so
the motion is carried
thank you everyone that's the motion
carried our next meeting
is scheduled for wednesday the 16th of
june
same place that's here thank you
everyone